شهدت القمه السعوديه الامريكيه في الرياض
توقيع عده اتفاقيات للتعاون العسكري
والاقتصادي وبيان الرؤيه المشتركه للبلدين
كما بحث الرئيس الامريكي والعاهل السعودي
ملفات المنطقه تمهيدا لقمه خليجيه امريكيه
واخرى عربيه اسلاميه
امريكيه
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا
ونناقش فيما وراءه ما مدى التباين في
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه تجاه العرب والشرق
الاوسط بين عهدي ترامب واوباما وما بدى
النتائج المحتمله
[موسيقى]
للاستدارة اول وجهه لزياره خارجيه يقوم
بها الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب منذ
توليه منصبه اعتبرته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
توبيخا لعهد سلفه باراك اوباما ولم يخفي
الجانبان الامريكي والسعودي تطلعهما الى
استعاده الشراكه بين البلدين الى سابق
اعادها واكد ذلك بتوقيع اتفاقيات تعاون
عسكري ودفاعي بقيمه
46 60 مليار دولار القمه السعوديه
الامريكيه تمهد لقمتين يوم الاحد احداهما
خليجيه امريكيه والاخرى عربيه اسلاميه
امريكيه تبحث قضايا مكافحه التطرف
والارهاب وملفات المنطقه الساخنه
والسياسات الايرانيه والتهديدات الاقليميه
نتابع تقرير زياد بركات ثم نفتح النقاش مع
ضيوفنا انه موسم العوده الى الخليج ترميم
للعلاقات وتجديدا للتحالفات وقد عصفت بها
تقلبات اوباما وانقلابات
ربما يفعل ترامب ذلك بمحمول رمزيه اللافته
يخص السعوديه باول زياره خارجيه له بل
ولاي رئيس امريكي منذ استقلال الولايات
المتحده ليس النفط وحسب ما يدفعه لذلك كما
يؤكد البعض ولا حتى صفقات السلاح بل ما
هورا
فملف ترامب في المنطقه لا تقف على قدمين
من دون تحالف صلب يشكل صخره لها يستقبل في
السعوديه بحفاوه نادره استثنائيه يمنح
ارفع الاوسمه يشرب الرجل القهوه العربيه
ومثله تفعل عقيلته وابنته اللتان حرصه على
زي محتشم ومعاصر معا يكسر اذا حاجز نفسي
في العلاقات التي تظهرها الصور دافئه
بلمسات شخصيه اما سياسيا فلدى العاهل
السعودي وترامب مواقف متقاربه ازاء ملفات
المنطقه باسرها بدءا من الحرب على الارهاب
انتهاء بالسلام ربما كما ان لديهم هواجس
تكاد تكون متطابقه ازاء اخرى فحتى قبل
فوزه بالرئاسه كانت ايران على اجنده الرجل
ولاحقا غير في بعض مواقفه وتراجع عن اخرى
باستثناء موقفه من طهران يراها واركان
ادارته خطرا في المنطقه وعليها وهو ما
يشاركه فيه العاهل السعودي بل والمنظومه
الخليجيه في عمومها مع بدء جوله ترامب كان
الشارع الايراني على الضفه الاخرى من
الخليج يترقب نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لقد اعلن فوز روحاني بينما ثمه من يقول
ويؤكد ان لا شيء يتغير هناك فمن يحكم ليس
من ينتخب بل من يتحكم بمفاصل المؤسسه كلها
اي هذا الرجل الذي يقول مساعدوه ان بلادهم
بفضله اصبحت تتحكم باربع عواصم عربيه هذا
ما قال رجاله ترامب انه يجب ان ينتهي فمن
الضاحيه الجنوبيه الى صنعاء وما بينهما
دمشق وبغداد ثمه اصابع ايران تعيث فسادا
وفقا لوصف البعض ويجب ان تضرب
وبقسوة ورات ل تجريبه وهدفها فيما يرى
زعماء في الخليج وواشنطن معا المزيد من
الهيمنه بقوه السلاح ترامب لم يخفي رفضه
لما قال انها سياسه سلفه ازاء ايران بدءا
من الاتفاق النووي وانتهاء بتدخلاتها ليس
الفرق هنا بين رجلين واسلوب بل بين
مقاربتين استراتيجيتين ادار اوباما عمليا
ظهره للخليج وكان اقرب الى ايران منه الى
دول مجلس التعاون وهو ما دفع العاهل
السعودي الى الاعتذار عن قمه دعي اليها
معه في البيت الابيض قبل ان يلتقيه لاحقا
ربما بشروط افضل وبذه اوباما تستدير
واشنطن الى حلفائها القدامى واليهم
تعود للمناقشه موضوع حلقتنا هذا ينضم
الينا من بيروت الدكتور فهد العرابي
الحارثي رئيس مركز اسبار للدراسات والبحوث
والاعلام وينضم الينا ايضا من واشنطن
السفير ادم ايرلي المتحدث السابق باسم
وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نرحب بضيفي اذا وابدا معك في
واشنطن سيد ادم ايرلي نريد ان نفهم مدى
التباين بين الرؤيه الامريكيه رؤيه ترامب
ورؤيه اوباما في في التعامل مع حلفاء
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه العرب وتحديدا
الخليجيين والتحديات التي
يواجهونها هذا سؤال وجيه اعتقد ان من
الواضح ان هنالك الكثير من الاختلافات لكن
في نفس الوقت هنالك العديد من نقاط
التشابه وبصراحه فان التحديات لم تتغير
كثيرا لنبدا مثلا بالاختلافات اكبر
الاختلافات من الواضح ان الرئيس ترامب قد
اسس علاقه شخصيه اقرب مع القياده في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهذا شيء كان
مفتقدا بشكل كبير في مع اداره اوباما
اوباما لم يكن له هذه الصداقه الحميمه مع
الملك او مع ولي ولي العهد او ولي العهد
وم قاده المنطقه لكن كان من الواضح منذ
اليوم الاول لاداره اوباما ان الرئيس
ترامب لديه شعور مختلف
وتقارب مختلف مع اصدقائه في الخليج وهذا
اعتقد ان هذا الامر كان واضحا بشكل كبير
بحقيقه اختياره المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كمحه اولى لزيارته وايضا العناق الاخوي
نوعا ما الذي والترحيب الذي تلقاه في
الرياض من جهه اخرى هنالك الكثير من
الاشياء التي لم تتغير الكثير تم التحدث
عنه حول صفقات السلاح بين الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه لكن من يجب علينا ان
نلاحظ امورا مهمه الكثير
من فقرات الدفاعيه والاسلحه الدفاعيه
كانت ضمن الاجراءات في سنوات العديده ضمن
اداره اوباما لذلك ما يقوم به ترامب هو
فقط التوقيع على اتفاقيه بدات في عهد
اوباما النقطه الثانيه بالرغم من كل لغه
الخطاب وا ايضا
اللغه السيئه اوضحت الولايات المتحده
بالنسبه التزاما قويا اظهرت التزاما قويا
وعسكريا ضد ايران يجب علينا ان نلاحظ ان
هناك شيء تغير ان ايضا قامت اداره ترامب
باطلاق مبيعات الاف 16 الى البحرين وايضا
مبيعات ستعزز الاسلحه السعوديه خاصه التي
يتم استخدمها في اليمن لكن بشكل اساسي فان
الشراكه الدفاعيه بين الولايات المتحده
منطقه الخليج كانت ثابته
وواضحه نقطه اخرى في حقيقه الا لم تتغير
كثيرا هي التحديات التي تواجهها المنطقه
والولايات المتحده وخاصه من ايران لذلك
السؤال الذي ربما ساطرح اذا ما
تخطينا حفلات العشاء والاستقبال
والخطابات وطرحنا سؤالا على انفسنا ما
الذي سيتغير حقا فيما يتعلق
برغبه وقدره الولايات المتحده في استخدام
قدرتها وقوتها من اجل محاربه ايران
وحمايه شركائنا وحلفائنا في المنطقه سواء
ما كان في اليمن او سوريا في العراق او في
البحرين هذا سؤال في حقيقه
الامر لم يجب عليه الرئيس ترامب او اي احد
من ادارتي لذلك السؤال الذي ساطرح عندما
يترك الرئيس ترامب السعوديه ع الى واشنطن
ما الذي سنراه يختلف فيما يتجاوز
المصافحات والاحضان و الاشياء الرسميه
اعتقد ان هذا الامر سيكون
حاسما د دعنا نقتبس منك سيد ادم ايرلي
اعذرني على المقاطعه ولكن ساخب منك هذا
السؤال الذي طرحته وهو سؤال جميل واحوله
الى الدكتور فهد الحارثي يعني يعني اذا
استثنينا يعني موضوع هذا هذه الحفلات
والاستقبال وال بهرجه الاستقبال والصور
والابتسامات وما الى ذلك وكنا قد شاهدنا
ذلك في بدايه عهد اوباما عندما قدم خطابه
الشهير في القاهره للعالم الاسلامي ثم لم
حدثت خيبه امر كبيره من باراك اوباما
اليوم ما الذي سيتغير فعلا هل هناك ثقه
عربيه خليجيه حقيقيه فعليه فيما يعد به
الرئيس الامريكي الجديد في هذه الزياره
اذا اردنا ان نذهب الى العمق قليلا في
تحليل او في المقاربات التي تناولت هذه
الزياره قبل قبل حدوثها وفي اثناء حدوثها
واليوم فانها ترتكز في الواقع على ثلاث
اشياء اساسيه ما يعطيها القيمه الحقيقيه
لها البعد الاول للزياره وهو بعد مقاربات
كثيره تحدثت عن انه احيانا ممكن يكون ديني
بمعنى انه في برنامج الرئيس اوباما يريد
ان يرى الفاتيكان وان يرى اسرائيل ثم بدا
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه كمعقم للاسلام
هناك البعد السياسي اليوم الدوله التي
تلعب تاثير حقيقي على مجريات الاحداث في
المنطقه العربيه عموما وليس فقط في منطقه
الخليج هي المملكه العربيه السعوديه سواء
في يعني في قيادتها لقوات التحالف في
اليمن او
ل يعني موقف من كثير من الاحداث التي تحدث
سواء في العراق او في سوريا او في غيرها
من المناطق العربيه وبالتالي صناعه القرار
العربي اليوم تكاد تكون الرياض تستاثر
بجزء كبيرا منه نظرا للدور المهم الذي
تلعبه على الساحه في مسائل الاشياء
الاقتصاديه الاخرى والاتفاقيات التي تمت
هذا امر طبيعي وهذا موجود وليس غريب وليس
جديد ان توقع المملكه او دول الخليج عقود
تسلح مع الولايات المتحده الا
الامريكيه هي فعلت ذلك دائما وستظل تفعله
وربما كان من المفروض انه ايضا يكون من
ضمن نشاطات او فعاليات هذه الزياره ان
يكون هناك توقيع لبعض الاتفاقيات اعود
فاقول
بانه العزله التي فرضها اوباما على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والانكفاء
الذي فرضه عليها خصوصا فيما يتعلق بمسائل
وقضايا الساخنه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ما
في شك انه وضع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في موق موقف لا تحسد عليه في موقف
اضعف صورتها الذهنيه في اذهان في اذهان
العالم كله واضعف ايضا موقعها في وجدان
اصدقائها وفي حلفائها التقليديين في
المنطقه لا سما ان الخطر الايراني كان
يتصاعد من وقت لاخر هدف وجود ترامب اليوم
ثلاث اهداف واضحه الهدف الاول هو محاربه
الارهاب واعتقد انه هذا يتفق
فيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه يتفق فيه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومع دول
الخليج الاخرى ومع دول العالم بشكل عام
وربما كانت القمه التي ستعقد غدا سواء
خليجيه او القمه الاخرى العربيه الاسلاميه
الامريكيه سيكون تركيزها بالدرجه الاولى
اقامه تحالف جديد او تحالف مهم او دعم
التحالفات القائمه اليوم للتركيز على
محاربه
الارهاب الخطوره الثانيه التي تتهدد
المنطقه غير الارهاب هي التصرفات
الايرانيه او التدخلات الايرانيه في شؤون
دول المنطقه ما اشار التقرير قبل قليل
الايرانيون يتباهون في كل مكان تصريحاتهم
على
مبهم دكتور فهد انت ذكرت يعني عده ابعاد
النقطه المتعلقه بمحاربه الارهاب البعد
الاقتصادي في هذه الزياره وموضوع ايران
يعني الا ترى ان يعني هذه الصفقات التي
اشرت اليها الان وهي بقيمه
460 مليار دولار يعني ينظر ينظر اليها
المراقبون على انه يعني مبلغ كبير جدا
بالنسبه لحجم الخطر الايراني الذي يعني
يشكل في النهايه عنوان لهذه الصفقات
لحمايه منطقه الخليج من الخطر الايراني هل
هناك توازن بين حجم الخطر والحمايه بهذا
المبلغ اولا انا لست متاكدا من الرقم نفسه
اللي هو 460 مليار دولار لانه هناك قام او
روايات اخرى حول هذا الرقم اذيعت هي اقل
من هذا الرقم بقليل واحيانا اقل من هذا
الرقم بكثير يعني قيل 110 خلال هذه
السنه قيل فوريا 110 و350 على مدار 10
سنوات ثم طرح رقم 460 مليار دولار لكن مش
مشكله يعني سنعتبر انه هناك تباين في هذه
الارقام مهما يكن الا تعتبر انه هذه
الارقام ثقيله
جدا
لا انا اعتقد انه حجم المخاطر التي تحيط
بمنطقه الخليج كمنط حيويه من الناحيه
الجيوسياسيه ومن الناحيه السياسيه ومن
الناحيه الاقتصاديه حجم هذا المخاطر يتطلب
ان تكون دول الخليج عموما والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم كدوله رائده على
قدر كبير من الاستعداد
ومن التيقظ للمستقبل
لانه التراخي ان صح التعب
الذي عرفت به دول مجلس التعاون في السنين
الماضيه كلفها كثيرا فيما اعتقد كلفها
كثيرا في العراق وكلفها كثيرا في اليمن
وكلفها كثيرا في حتى بعض دول الخليج مثل
البحرين وغيرها اغر دوله عدوانيه مع الاسف
الشديد مثل ايران جاره الخليج المزعجه
طبعا والتي تتدخل دائما في شؤونها اغراها
هذا التراخي الخليجي
بان يعني تعوس فسادا في هذه المنطقه كما
اشار تقريركم وهذا تعبيركم وانا اؤيد
التعبير
تماما يعني انا اعتقد انه لابد من ان يكون
هناك تركيز على تسليح هذه الدول والتركيز
ايضا على انشاء صناعات للاسلحه في هذه
الدول كما تفعل ايران نفسها اليوم ايران
اليوم لها لها باع طويل في الصناعات
العسكريه
وصناعات استاذنك في اخت فاصل دكتور فهد
وادم ايرلي سوف نعود بعد فاصل قصير لنناقش
بعد الفاصل النتائج المحتمله
[موسيقى]
للاستدارة
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش ابعاد الاستداره
الامريكيه تجاه العرب ومنطقه الشرق الاوسط
في عهد دونالد ترامب ونتائجها المحتمله
على التعامل مع ملفات منطقه اهلا بكم وبضي
فينا واتحول الى واشنطن وسيد ادم يرلي كنا
قبل الفاصل قد بدانا في الحديث عن موضوع
ايران وبالمناسبه اليوم طبعا اعلن عن فوز
حسن روحاني برئاسه ايران اليوم نريد ان ان
نفهم اذا هل تشكلت برايك سيد ايرلي رؤيه
امريكيه جديده مغايره بالنسبه للاداره
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بايران وتح تحركاتها
الاقليميه المقلقه في اليمن في سوريا في
العراق وفي اماكن
اخرى نعم اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ان هنالك العديد
من التطورات المهمه في هذا المجال التي
ترتبت من هذه الزياره بدايه بالذهاب الى
الرياض
وايضا باستضافه الصاحب جلاله الملك سلمان
للقمه العربيه الاسلاميه بوجود قاده عرب
مسلمين من عده دول يعرضوا هذا امرا مهما
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بايران يعرضوا ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي القوه الاكبر
في المنطقه سواء كانت اقتصاديا ام كان
الامر كان اقتصاديا او عسكريا او ايضا
بالسلطه الدينيه ايران كانت تطرح الكثير
من الاسئله حول قدره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه حول مساله
اداره الحرمين الشريفين اعتقد ان هنالك
الكثير من القاده ارسلوا رساله واضحه الى
ايران او اي جهه تشك بقدره سعوديه على
كونها تقوم باستضافه او بالرعايه الحرمين
هذا امر وهذا مؤشر جيد النقطه الثانيه
دعونا نكون بغايه الوضوع خلال السنوات
الثمان الماضيه وتحت اداره اوباما كانت
الولا المحده منسحب من المنطقه وكانت
ايران تتقدم الولايات المتحده انسحبت من
العراق ورفضت ان تنخرط في سوريا وحاولت ان
تحاول ان تحوي ايران
وعقد الاتفاق النووي ورفع العقوبات كل هذا
الفراغ الذي خلفته الولايات المتحده الذي
استغلته ايران واستفادت منه في العراق وفي
سوريا وفي اليمن وفي
البحرين بجعل الرئيس ترامب المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبقائه قاد دول الخليج
هو يرسل رساله مهمه الى ايران مفادها ان
امريكا لن تسمح لطهران سواء كان يحكمها
رئيسي او روحاني او اي شخص ان امريكا لن
تسمح لايران بان تكون لديها مطلق في مساله
تقويض استقرار حلفائها النقطه الاخرى التي
اريد ان اذكرها ولا يتحدث عنها الكثير هنا
ان من المهم جدا معرفه ان دونالد
ترامب يجلس على الكثير من ال القنابل التي
لم تتفجر في البيت الابيض وهي قنابل
موقوته وما اشير اليه هو مساله التحقيق في
وزاره العدل والاف بي اي في ادارته وحملته
وعلاقته المحتمله بالروس وربما النشاطات
غير القانونيه بالكثير من مستشاريه هذه
مشكله
ستنفذ الكثير من انتباهي ووقت الرئيس
ترامب وجهدي ادارته مخاوفي ان المبادره
والبدايه الرايعه التي تم تحقيقها من هذه
الزياره قد ربما تنحرف عن مسارها وتفقد
زخمها بسبب المشاكل الداخليه في الولايات
المتحده طيب دكتور فهد الحارثي اذا كان
ترامب بتعبير ادم ايرلي يجلس على قنابل
موقوته في البيت الابيض بسبب المشاكل
الكثيره التي يتعرض لها والتسريبات
والتحقيقات وما الى ذلك الى اي درجه يمكن
ان يعني يعني تنجز هذه التفاهمات التي يتم
التوصل اليها وتتحول الى اليات عمل حقيقيه
واقعيه على الارض فيما يتعلق بايران وب
امور
اخرى اولا لابد ان نعترف بانه بالفعل
الرئيس دونالد ترامب لديه عدد ب قنابل كما
قال ضيفك الكريم من واش واشنطن
وهو يعني وهي وهي ليست سهله لكن ايضا
ينبغي ان لا نضخم من هذا الموضوع كثيرا
لان هذا الموضوع يعني يحتاج الى الى عمل
طويل وشاق وليس من السهوله بمكان ان ننساق
وراء ما يتردد من انه احتمال ان الرئيس
دونالد ترامب يجد صعوبات في ولايته او
ربما حتى بعض المقاربات تقول ربما انه لن
يكمل ال ولايته هذا كلام يعني سابق لاوانه
من جهه ومن جهه اخرى ليس بالسهوله في دوله
ا يعني مؤسسات مثل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا من جهه الجهه الاخرى انا
يهمني بالدرجه الاولى ان اليوم في الرياض
يتشكل
نظام امني وسياسي
عالمي هدفه الاساس هو تركيز الامن في هذا
العالم عن طريق محاربه الارهاب من جهه وعن
طريق تقليم اظافر اي دوله تتوقع انها
تستطيع ان تتخطى حدودها وتتدخل في شؤون
دول اخرى فتسبب لها القلاقل وتزعزع هذا كل
هذا فق المقه ارهاب الار نعم كل كل هذا
والسؤال لادم يرلي يعني هناك احساس لدى
البعض بانه ياتي على
حساب القضيه الفلسطينيه برايك ما الذي
يحمله الرئيس الامريكي بشان ما يوصف ب
يعني ام الصراعات في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وهي القضيه
الفلسطينيه في هذا هذا سؤال مثير للاهتمام
لانني اعتقد ان القضيه
الفلسطينيه ستكون ضمن المواضيع التي سيتم
مناقشتها ضمن المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده دعونا نتذكر ان صاحب
الجلاله اقترح مبادره السلام في سنه 2002
من قبل صاحب الجلاله الملك عبد الله
واعتقد ان هذه هي القاعده الاساسيه
لمناقشه نوع من التسويه بين فلسطينين
واسرائيل لذلك المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والعالم العربي سيلعبون دورا مهما في
تحقيق السلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين واعتقد ان دونالد ترامب
سيذهب الى القدس يوم غد او بعد غد حسب
اعتق دي برساله مفادها انه اذا لم يكن فقط
التعاون لكن هنالك رساله بالتاكيد ان
العالم العربي مستعد لدعم
مفاوضات مفاوضات فلسطينيه
واسرائيل لدي لدينا نعم ثوان دكتور فهد هل
هذا ممكن ما الذي يمكن ان يلعبه العرب
كدور في هذا
الشان
ذلان او من تخاذل اوباما فيما يتعلق
بموضوع حل القضيه الفلسطينيه اوباما وعد
من السنه الاولى في ولايته الاولى بانه
سيكون هناك دوله للفلسطينيين دوله مستقله
وتكون عاصمتها القدس الان وليس عن اوباما
لانه ليس معنا وقت الان الان وهو يتحدث عن
نقل السفاره الى القدس وما الى ذلك انا
انا انا اعتقد ان السياسه الامريكيه اليوم
ستستفيد وبالذات الرئيس ترامب سيستفيد
من الفشل الذي تحقق في عهد اوباما وسيحاول
ان ينجز شي العرب مقبلون على السلام من
خلال مبادره السلام التي
قدموها نتوقف عند هذا الحد اشكرك جزيل
الشكر واعذرني على المقاطعه الدكتور فهد
العرابي الحارثي رئيس مركز اسبار للدراسات
والبحوث والاعلام ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من
واشنطن السفير ادم ايرلي الطب المنى والى
اللقاء
س